foreign
I don't know I'll tell you what we're
doing we're introducing Our Guest
uh uh you may know her as Forest mommy
on Twitter uh Jessica finsky how are you
I don't hear you are you talking uh-oh
you're mute a mute on Zoom you're on
Zoom yes this is already a disaster
you know that that journalist is
completely right about you you know
everything they said how you doing
thanks for being here
thank you for being here we appreciate
it now I know you wouldn't have me I
don't know why I look so bright right
now there's kind of I have sorry don't
worry you're in the you don't look this
beautiful don't do filters and [__] okay
so don't worry you're in the middle of
us you'll look great by comparison no
matter what so you'll be fine that's one
thing I will say she's very beautiful
extremely humble too yeah yeah super
humble uh
how humble I am no it's it's like she
was telling people to stop being ugly
stop being ugly I'm like [__] this and
this amount of troll the amount of
trolling that she does and people just
[__] bite it they buy into it and
it's so angry I gotta say that uh I have
been following you for a while and uh
while I am a fan of a uh you know an
attractive woman on social media I'm
really just more I'm having more fun
watching how much you [__] annoy the
[__] out of people it's as a kindred
spirit uh on Twitter it's fun to watch
people just just poke just poke at
people and then walk away for a few
hours
but I hate it they hate when you kind of
mirror them if you're like near them and
then they can see how like truly
despicable they are oh they lose their
minds and by this is so so you're
running for a city council District Four
right our Veda is am I saying that right
it's our bad it's Arvada well I'm not
from Colorado we're from Florida thank
God
I'm not going to be one of those like
I'm like a strickler but yeah it's our
best it sure seems like district four
um well I I this is this part you know
I've been following you for a bit but I
I will say that this this this
Jeremy Jeremy JoJo is that his am I
saying it right he's so he says he's
brown he's a brown person we found
poster he's like I'm Brown because he
has a Hispanic sounding last name so
joshola
it looks pretty [__] white to me
though and and apparently uh you tweeted
out if you live it if you if if you live
in the city of Arvada did I say it right
this time
no but of course I did whatever uh me
just talk about me this Jesus Christ The
Troll us uh this may this may be of
interest an anti-vaxxer who hates
government is seeking to become part of
the government and I'm like based like
what's the problem with that she also
hates local journalists you better stop
Mercer fall in love and then Jessica
Minsky his father affidavit uh for a
console seat and a threat a thread on
Jessica online so who is this guy
so he works for a local on like a local
TV station out here called nine news
which used to be owned by tegna which
tegna is run by Pfizer but
um so he's just a one of these we don't
even watch the news but I've got on
Twitter so much over the last three
years I would see these these like
idiots that would work for nine news
Denver there's like four or five of
these dudes and they are just like they
sniff their own farts so hard every
[__] morning like they're the worst
people every time like they got proven
wrong they got worse and he was stalking
me because I had called him out because
he's threatened to dock people like this
like multiple times multiple times
there's like proof of it on Twitter of
him threatening to docs people and do
all this [__] so he must I had him
blocked and he had me blocked because
one of the threads in there he was like
I have her blocked and here's the
picture I have from her timeline like
how creepy is that that's just creepy on
its face right yeah and then uh yeah and
then he posted that 12 hours after I
filed so I don't even want to be in
politics I'm doing this because I feel
like I have to and then this
[__] does that 12 hours after
like like my first 12 hours in so I
don't know anything about this guy
they're like Psychopaths they're legit
Psychopaths that work out these places
because they get away with stalker
they're stalkers like they're stalkers
with licenses to be called journalists
but they're stalkers that's all they are
yeah I mean I'm not a fan of journalists
I don't know what this guy does but just
just based on his pfp alone I want to
bury my fist in his Bread Basket like
he's it's I like that is an enrageous
profile picture she is you know what I
mean he looks like he's like auditioning
for a sitcom where he's like the hip
young dad whose wife he lost at a young
age and now he's just trying to pick up
the pieces man in his Latino
neighborhood like it's what made him
first dislike me is one time he shared
something where he was like I had to
drive an hour to get this file because
they didn't have it online so I shared
it and I was like like oh at 10 live at
10 journalist complains about doing
journalism and then like ever since then
the dude like hated me most of
Journalism now is just seen with
something's trending on Twitter and then
writing a story about it no one does
actual [__] journalism yeah I mean
come on go easy on the guy it's been six
years of just handing whatever doctored
things that the CIA gives you all right
we're just running with this right okay
cool and you'll back me up right yeah
bro we got your okay as long as you're
gonna back me up on this safe and
effective
safe and effective yeah I know it's
that's and that's and that's exactly but
it's it's my favorite tweet was the one
though for with the beer oh my God I
don't know who that was but it was from
this other side here it is I was just
saying I sent you my retweet on [__]
because so many people were just
retweeting this and like bass is she
single yeah she does a YouTube live
stream where she gets [__] up her
words and talks about covet conspiracies
uh lgbtq people libertarian politics I
don't talk about [__] LGBT like I
talk about people like I talk about
people like how narcissistic well I'm
sorry but I'll have you know that Heidi
Beadle called you a real piece of work
a real piece of work I have a feeling
that that that's a redacted statement
yeah because I know how women speak
about each other and I know I know for a
oh okay well they wait even though but
you know what trans women love the uh
yeah trans women love the old uh trans
women
Heidi looks like she spared no expense
at a dinosaur park
she says piece of work but I know behind
the scenes how women talk and the word
[__] definitely was thrown around oh
yeah for sure
that word was definitely thrown that's
like telling me you were hanging around
America first and you didn't hear one N
word it's like come on you heard one at
least in the bathroom uh yeah so she
wrote this like is it a she or he like
is it what is that trans woman is it for
real it's a dude all right yeah I can't
tell oh my God so it's a dude so this
dude's mad and they're anti-fud and all
this [__] they were like involved in all
the riots and [__] in 2020. wait
anti-what
Oh I thought you said anti-fun I was
like oh I was like okay well we know
they're anti-fun remember when [__]
were synonymous with fun yeah no they
used to be like oh trash shows and fun
in the adult district and now it's like
we're grooming your kids there's nothing
you can do about it and also you're not
allowed to use any words what oh no
[__] you'll take [__] from my cold
dead hands
um so yeah it's funny because it seems
it's such a deceiving article I was
reading the article before the show and
uh it's a Colorado Times Recorder which
everyone that's like burning off the
presses it's basically we're the [__]
Superman works and I I was reading it
and it's basically it's you know you
guys
Libertarians went to a free Julian
Assange rally right so in the article
you think oh this is going to be about a
free Trulia songs rally and it's like
one paragraph and the rest is just like
and this piece of [__] this [__]
[__] what a [__] [__] this [__] is
I'm like wow why don't you just i title
this Forest mommy's a horde like it's
easier
it was such a false you know I'm
thinking hear me out on this you throw a
fake mustache on you're a trans man oh
God you don't change anything else about
your appearance your name yes anything
you're just like I'm a dude and you have
to respect that now you know
statistically speaking you know we
usually vote for white men in this
country I think it'll work in your favor
yeah
and that the people in my city who are
running as well they sign this stupid
pledge it was a stupid like [__]
we're gonna run a Clean Campaign and
disavow people and listen that and I was
like I refuse to sign that [__] I'm like
I'm not signing that [__] [__] so in
another article the guy brought that up
so if I do that I can be like I'm
holding you to that [__] pledge
[__] like and if you if you
deny my existence as a trans man then
you you're failing your pledge so yeah
the last the last time my town made me
sign a pledge I said [__] no all that
shit's going in the same garbage can I
don't give a [__] I don't have time to
be sorting through all this [__] I'll
sign the pledge but I'm not recycling
[__] everything's going in the same
[__] can but it's it's it it really
it really was first off this whole let's
have a clean I love this so let's have a
Clean Campaign yeah I know you made
people get [__] vaccinated and wear
masks and [__] made their kids
[__] but now you know what let's be
nice to each other [__] you why would
why would you ever want to be nice to
these people I don't want they're so
mean bro attack me yeah I'll Attack
these the media all three media articles
have attacked me now so it's like you
got what the [__] like you guys are
protecting me or helping me out so so
what are you running on what's the
what's the big uh what's the what's the
platform
uh well there's like some local issues
at this funny brought up trash before we
they tried to push through this like
trash Monopoly that they were still
paying a tax on even if you opt out I
will tackle that [__] and then they have
to like build a Tollway at one point in
this one area in the in my district that
everyone's all pissed off about so we're
gonna have to figure that out but I'm
really just like anti-tax Pro business
I'm a 2A absolutist free speech
absolutist and I'm like I'm not gonna
Alex Stein but I'm gonna I'm gonna make
a plan at these district meetings at our
Council meetings um but that's what you
have to do the message of [__] the
government that's what you have to do
you have to that's what you have to do
you I mean at this point I mean only
supporting people who want to dismantle
exactly exactly and I don't mean like
lower taxes I mean literally dismantle
the entire thing yeah no we were just
talking about like this the ATF agent
that doesn't know I'm not an expert on
Firearms like it's your [__] job
like you know what that is I'm not a
[__] well that's like the Ruth Chris
the [__] Ruth Chris guy the Ruth main
roof Chef or with Chris I'm not an
expert at Stakes you [__] should be
it's your one job yeah it's so it's
because but yeah I'm Pro dismantle the
government take the whole thing down
we'll have a rough couple months and
then everything will be paradise after
that I mean
a couple months where it's a little
Rocky and we'll be fine
I mean and and you know isn't Colorado
another one of those little more
libertarian Havens unique wasn't one of
the first states that used to be it used
to be very libertarian out here but then
like all the cities Denver is [__] up
we just passed even our state bill they
just basically passed Ohio we can trans
your kids bills so like and with trans
affirming care and all that [__] and not
having to tell parents if your minors
are uncontroceptive then like just [__]
and they take pictures of them like it's
so creepy and my house District
representative is a trans woman I have
no idea how she she I'm gonna say he you
guys it's Rumble we don't give a [__]
revenge of the CIS I don't care no
no me now but I'm sure you guys get hang
washed all the time that's our
I don't know I'm pretty sure every
single person that watches me loves me
yeah well that's because any criticisms
ever because you're a narcissist and I
also never read YouTube comments well I
wouldn't
I'm hot but they may still hate me and
that
generally when I when I think women are
hot I end up hating them so it's fine
that's nothing wrong with that I love
that [__] like I don't care as long
as you think that makes so many people
mad it's so brilliant troll it really go
it's good it's a classic but it's it's
used to be ugly too so like it's totally
perfect because I'm totally like not
shallow but I am I could totally I am
[__] shallow this is the ATF thing I
was talking about as a gun owner of many
different types in a 20-year military
veteran I have some expertise in
Weaponry uh and self-defense weapons and
uh protecting poppy fields and the
pedophiles that own those poppy fields
I'm sorry
and the Iron Dome 10 seconds would you
define an assault weapon for me so
if you go after 15 seconds I'll just
interrupt you so so I'll go shorter than
that because I I honestly I do think
that's a if Congress wishes to take that
up I think Congress would have to do the
work but we would be there to provide
technical assistance I unlike you I'm
not a Firearms expert to the same extent
as you may be but you should be the
Pinnacle of firearm expert yeah it's
like I said earlier Grantham should be
in charge of the ATF that guy knows
everything about guns well he they are
expert at killing a bunch of children
that are they're in a church in Waco
they're really good at that yeah that's
true but we didn't use guns as much as
fire we burned them to death which is
way worse honestly if you think about it
we just burned him to death yeah that's
a little bit [__] worse I'd rather be
shot yeah I mean me too it's it's just
[__] the people the people that run
the government the guy the FAA guy that
had no idea how you're gonna fly a plane
it's like what not only not knew how to
fly a plane he knew nothing about any of
like any of the procedures having to do
with because even remember when we
watched that video and I said well maybe
he wasn't a pilot right but the FAA head
could also have been a former air
traffic controller maybe you don't know
[__] about flying a plane but he may
know everything about the air patterns
and the you know emergency you know
procedures he knew nothing I don't think
this man knew how airplanes work no or
radar worked it was the funniest [__]
ever I'm like wow this guy knows nothing
I'm not sure how these metal Birds even
get in the sky oh [__] it was the
funniest [__] ever that guy was great
okay so you were you were singing in the
chat earlier what what do you think
about Elon Musk because we're kind of in
the same boat where I don't trust this
guy I think he's an antichrist yeah what
do you think
Yeah well yeah because the Antichrist is
very likable yeah right like everybody
loves him even from both from all blocks
we probably everyone loves some he
performs Miracles all that kind of [__]
I mean it's kind of you know
it's kind of like any time I can
understand because anytime I talk
against neural link people are like well
it's gonna help I don't like people walk
and [__] and I'm like I don't okay but
like you're still putting something in
someone's brain and with it's techno I
mean if you you know pacemakers that
keep Hearts going the information that
those can hold and the things that those
little things do there so can you
imagine like when you're tapping into
the Mainframe up here like how well I
mean I mean he just went in a whole rant
like you know and he was right about his
rant about how a dangerous hey I could
be but it's like okay but you also want
to put you want to put like computers in
people's brain to win the AI gets in
your brain we have zombies like I don't
understand like the [__] with [__]
with people's minds and then the problem
is is that then it becomes what then you
know what's going to happen we're gonna
start they're going to start just
pulling they're doing it from your
social media you're going to sign you're
not gonna know you're gonna sign up for
the new Twitter X and every time you
think something it's going to be
uploaded to an ad agency so they can
like sell you some Uggs well also did
you read the the stuff about the neural
link and like the like all the the
testing they're doing on like monkeys
and [__] like like these monkeys were
being [__] tortured they're putting
neural links in these monkeys and it's
making them go [__] crazy and have
like a bunch of pain and anxiety and
they're like ripping each other's
[__] eyeballs and dicks off and
they're going [__] insane and just
like ripping everything why would you
say would you say they're going bananas
I I would use a more sensitive word for
that but sure okay sure they're going
bananas you're going banana but yeah
this is the thing they want to put in
our brain and they're like there's been
studies where they're like the [__]
conditions of these animal Labs that
they're putting animals into neural ink
and oh yeah no I don't no thanks I just
want to die naturally like normal like
of liver cancer in 10 years wow 10 years
probably you're giving yourself that
long yeah that's amazing to me yeah well
remember I have a lot of spite to run on
yeah well that's true uh which but but
yeah I mean do you do you think he's
he's actually out for like the greater
good or this dude's out for himself it
feels like he's just out for the memes
you know
I mean I can't I can't I just can't
trust them 100 he's funny he's hilarious
he's trolling and I love trolling like
but in the end when you're in that club
you know it shows you how much like the
[__] crowd bad the crybabies are on
Twitter that is even if the Antichrist
is just good at trolling you're like
yeah but I'd rather deal with him
because he's funny you know what I mean
even knowing that you're like I mean
look I get it he's probably the devil
but bro he just [__] switched
supposed to see on our way out we might
as well laugh so we said we're totally
clown filled at this point but like with
the CBC thing where he you know he
stated we're like we're not 100
government funded he's switching to 70
and then it'd be a dick 69 percent
it's so child and it was just a sea of
people going nice nice
I was in there too there was me you know
a thousand other people going nice
it's so childish look this whole thing's
gonna go over a cliff anyway I might as
well go out laughing
so I fill up the campaign especially to
him like at this point they've made a
joke out of it more than I have so now
I'm just going to continue on that path
and yeah but but now here's the thing
though this this is Streisand effect
right like they push people and they
push you into relevancy now now more
people care about what you're doing than
about their stupid [__] you know what I
mean and and that means this is some
like dumb girl in the suburbs and like
okay I had a little bit of a Twitter
following from some stunts as well as
just because I'm awesome but like then
like they pushed me out and they like
they made me more famous than I could I
couldn't even paid for the amount of
Impressions he got me you know so yeah
one of the main videos that I told you
before on Twitter that I found you on
was with you had this the Fourth of July
or had a sparkler in your head you saw
it you were OG you saw it I'm OG oh yeah
no no I saw it I know I saw it I played
it on my show I was like this and then I
I think I we we saluted so yeah that's
what I remember so now of course in
their little circle jerks and all these
little town halls they're like can you
believe this you're making a mockery out
of this anyway let's [__] embezzle
money and take kids lunch money oh that
sounds great like everything's shitty
and weird I've done is out there and
nothing's been shitty it's just been
weird fun not even we had fun you
drinking a phone gives a [__] like
that's the other problem everybody's
gotten so stupid now like every little
thing and the right does it too man the
right does it a lot where every little
thing is like an offense where like if
you've had any sort of [__] past like
that's it [__] you bro what you had a
different opinion when you were 25
you're a piece of [__] like what calm
down man
you know we all listen all of us went
the Hot Topic at one point it wasn't our
fault this was at the mall leave me
alone okay
you're more about you're more of a
Spencer's gal
you might have glad you're having a
Leanne on too yeah because she gets it
of course because she's definitely more
she's more Trump than I am for the
conservatives they like go at her and
it's just like [__] off people like who
gives a [__] who care by the way by the
way I'm not raping kids and I do
everything with adults and like you know
I'm sorry I'm appropriate but
inappropriate but you guys want to like
[__] kids [__] penises off like
what's [__] yeah it really it really it
really is but it really it really is
getting kind of out of control where
most because I think that's what's
happening now we talk about on the show
like even normies now are like hey man
I'm not even political but this shit's
getting really [__] weird you know
like where people start going like why
are they like showing sex books at
school that seems odd yeah I I remember
the days of if a teacher ever spoke to
me about half of the things that kids
get talked to nowadays that would have
been angry [__] dads uncles Moms
showing up [__] tire irons in their
hands and [__] that was a different era
people would have been like the [__] you
talking to my kid about [__] no no no
bring them out here and back then even
principals and other teachers would be
like hey man that's not him you wanna
you wanna go deal with that go deal with
that bro I didn't say nothing you care
about no sex bro I'm a math teacher and
nowadays it's like now it's a
prerequisite you are going to let us
groom your [__] kids there's gonna be
no discussion about it or if not you're
a bigot and they keep expanding the
definition of bigot to include a lot of
sensible things nowadays so the
Coalition of bigots is starting to grow
and I don't think the word has the
strength it used to because for a few
years ago it was like oh you're a bigot
you want Jews to be locked up in camps
and [__] burned to death and you want
to [__] kick all the black people out
of the country and you're like well I
know I'm not zielinsky yeah exactly and
now they're like no you won't let me cut
your kid's dick off and molest him at 10
years old you're a [__] bigot bro and
now it's like why are the why are the
bleachers full of bigots growing why are
there why are there so many like card
carrying bigots now it's I expanded it
too much and now people are like they
made words meaningless that's the
problem problem is like once you call
somebody a [__] Nazi like what do you
I don't care what you call me after that
I don't give a [__] like the the things
start getting better I think when people
stop giving [__] when people say camera
I don't care what you think about me I
don't really give a flying [__] and
that's the point because I think a lot
of these [__] [__] neocon shitty
conservatives like oh we don't want to
be called the racist and then they
[__] rape us you know it's like no I
don't give a [__] what the [__] you call
me how's that sound you know Dan
Crenshaw you [__] neocon piece of
[__] pirate [__] [__] I hate him
more than any other politician I think
yeah can you primary him that'd be fun
yeah move to Texas
yeah we'll get you a nice eye patch
we'll make it like very girly oh yeah
we'll get you a very girly eye pack
actually gonna like very like a
sunflower accentuate your features I
really like that yeah yeah and then you
could be like yeah [__] this guy he's a
[__] loser hear me out on this skull
mask pattern on an eye patch but like in
like bedazzled I like that listen girly
but like eco-fashion yeah we'll run your
campaign for free we got you like we
we'll beat Crenshaw she was led to
volunteer any help they want us those
are like speech writing where anyone has
any input hit me up yeah I've been
throwing my ideas out there for years
nobody will hire me remember the
Bloomberg thing he ended up dropping out
from the presidential thing at like two
percent yeah and I was like I could have
gotten Bloomberg up to like five percent
if he had just my whole my whole
campaign idea for him was lean into the
super villain [__] yes be like yeah you
fat [__] losers shouldn't have soda
because you pour sugar you're gonna make
everything illegal because you're all
disgusting [__] animals with no self
[__] control and I'm gonna rule the
world and block out the sun guarantee
you he would have been less boring he
would have got at least three point bump
on the pulse but he didn't listen to me
but if you listen we get the skull mask
eye patch we're running against Crenshaw
you can't lose everyone hates Crenshaw
and then you go out there and you say
things like Crenshaw deserve to lose his
eye he's a [__] and just really lean
into it like hard like hard it's Rumble
we can say what we want yank that thing
right off his face and go I don't
believe you okay genetically to a
horrified crowd and then there'll be a
hole in there and then you go inside you
go and then you go look free campaign
advice boy the people that are watching
right now are really going to be mad at
this episode hi Colorado hi Colorado
and don't worry about it
I'm like I had to me I don't care and if
I don't win whatever at least I've got
the message out and got some of these
[__] to listen so you have a show
though right what's your plug your show
too so people know where to watch you
that's it's Forest Mommy and Rumble and
YouTube I've tried to be on Rebel more
than YouTube for obvious reasons yeah
you need a clip of that beer drinking in
your intro bro you really do that should
be the intro to your show that right
there they if they always mean stuff
that's cool they think it's bad it's
like you're [__] shooting back a beer
like she looks [__] everybody by the way
to be fair a lot of the comments that's
my like they live sunglasses on too and
I'm like
it's and by the way I love that it's
like the lady the lady telling you that
literally wants a mutilate her penis and
they're mad that you're drinking a
couple brewskies with the Bros it's like
seriously that's worse than mutilating
your genitals all right yeah I love the
hard-hitting journalism now going to
people's freely out there content being
like Oh my God and it's like oh yeah
there's a lot of us who have mine being
real and putting our real opinions out
there we put all we have so much content
out there now for like the last two
years and it's like oh you're so
hard-hitting finding something clicking
on my link then had posted to get some
like information it's so dumb yeah it's
so awful whenever they try that [__]
with us we're like you should see this
stuff YouTube deleted if you think this
is bad you should see the stuff they
[__] took down that was the stuff
they let stay up yeah this is the stuff
that they allowed you know all those
[__] and Weirdos where you live in
Colorado you don't have to worry about
me and Royce ever coming and bothering
you and I'll tell you why because if I'm
getting on a plane for five hours I'm
flying the extra hour we're just gonna
go to Vegas we're going to Vegas weed's
legal there and they're not Colorado and
it's not cold not as cold we're from
Florida so we're Swamp People
yeah I try not to leave the state we're
Swamp People yeah Florida's great
everybody's moving there a lot of people
left don't they did please stop no it's
true I'm not I'm staying in Colorado and
if it gets completely [__] over I'm
gonna be in the trees sniping them until
I go out no that's it well yeah well
they're not gonna grab that and I said
that'll be that'll be a sound but listen
that you know that's even the worst
thing anyone said in our show we always
bring up when Alex Jones was on her show
the very big inside don't worry guys I
know you're on YouTube I'm not gonna do
anything too bad 15 minutes later I
think we got to start killing
politicians I'm like well well there
goes this episode yeah and trying to
fist fight Matthew McConaughey
okay well thanks Alex hey at least we
you know at least we eased on the brakes
a little bit today Jesus
oh my God
never been around him in person yeah we
just we just we were just we were just
saying we just we met him when we were
over in Austin we did Infowars uh he's a
great does he have like have like like
Just Vibe to him that just like there's
an energy I will agree because I'm
biased because I've no I've like I grew
up on him so like I've been listening to
him for like over 22 years so like he's
my internet dad so I was a little more
oh but like you know it's yeah he
definitely has a [__] presence he
wouldn't he wouldn't have lasted this
long if he [__] didn't have some kind
of you know presence to him we uh yeah
we when we boys yeah here you go uh
we'll pull it up yeah that's it when we
when we were there
when we when we were out when we were
just [__] we were hanging out with
Harrison Smith because we had finished
doing a show and went to his office and
as soon as we turned you could hear him
from like I would sit for like a mile
away so all you hear about you here is
like we don't hear what he's saying it
was so far but you hear the voice you
hear that and we turn and I go is that
it oh [__] it's Alex and then he walks
up and goes hey fellas because he's been
on a show before he's like hey bro we
got what did I do look at this guy says
what do you guys doing and he's he's
like chain smoking a cigarette walking
back and forth and the one thing that
I'll tell you surprised me about Alex
was I shook his hand and I put my arm
like on his arm he's a [__] unit like
he is he is solid I guess a solid man
like if he'd hit you would [__] hurt
yeah so but I mean yeah the info Works
people man I what they did to them is is
so [__] wrong it's disgusting and
they're doing it to Fox now too yeah I
mean Fox Will Survive but it's still
[__] up with their like setting all
these precedents where they're basically
making real journalism illegal and
um you know unless you push the status
quo we'll just sue you for seven
gajillion dollars it's just a made-up
number and we'll just take it and you'll
have no life infowar Infowars can't this
is this is the truth Infowars can't even
get creamer and sugar without asking
permission now because from the court
like there when you're there like they
have to ask permission for everything
because he had an opinion that people
didn't [__] like oh and they're
trying to take his [__] cat oh yeah
they're trying it's family yeah there's
a cute cat it was like yeah it's a color
like my cat I like those cats yeah
that's uh [__] I forgot the cat's name I
know me of all people how did you forget
he was holding it it was all like
flopping around made a video with it
somebody in the chat will know it yeah
it's like Moshi or something like that
or um there's like something something
Japanese sounding yeah it was egg roll
egg roll that's what there it is it was
said yeah I was like I'm pretty sure it
was it was egg roll oh so who do you
want to be president uh
is it Mrs or miss mommy
I'm not legally married now okay so how
about this how about this that much how
about Miz Ms mommy with two Z's okay how
I just love that people still coming for
us mommy even though they found out my
real name now like yeah like but that's
how it happens like even our producer
like frozen Asian for example that's his
name we know his real name but we even
we just call him that because that's
that's the name we know now that's
that's how they know you
uh who do you want to be president
um Dave Smith okay I know anyone to be
friends yeah I was I mean I know we're
not gonna ever win that right Dave's
never gonna win it I know he's not we
know we're not [__] like we know the
facts here right but he can get the
message out and so I would him but I I
don't pay enough attention to like the
federal [__] because [__] the federal
[__] especially the libertarian Federal
[__] they're also like like in
and I do like Massey he would be a
pretty cool president I suppose if
someone had to be a president
or Rand but it's true we do talk about
that a lot about about when voting how
we said in this last election now your
local elections mean so much so for your
day-to-day life
means so much [__] more than the
federal [__] because that's that that's
your sh that's your property taxes right
like that that that's that's your
garbage [__] pickup things that
people take for granted that's the [__]
that [__] affects your day-to-day
life you know um and and uh that those
are the people that you that you really
like well we're in Polk County which is
you know Grady Judd the guy who's always
on the the crazy Sheriff that's always
on TV and it's actually pretty cool
place to be in Polk County because
during the during the Floyd stuff he
came on TV he's like this is Florida if
someone goes through your door you blast
them out with a shotgun I'm like [__] it
bass hell yeah buddy and that's another
good thing sheriffs too like if if those
are the people you want to make sure
that you get sheriffs in that are super
pro Second Amendment you know [__] like
that and and I think that matters a lot
more than whoever the CIA has in power
or the president
area of voting so like I'll have there's
basically going to be probably ten
thousand to eleven thousand people
voting in my district so that's like the
smallest amount where you can find out
if there is funny business we're gonna
[__] know because like the support I
have the GOP out here is supporting me
even though I'm a [__] nut and they
know it they're like
following you on Twitter for years and
I'm like oh Lord
[Laughter]
isn't that that happens it's not the
worst when somebody tells you that this
happens to us a lot we're like someone
of a higher you know I would say like
class or was like or your tier system is
like oh yeah I've been following you
guys forever I'm like everything oh yeah
like all of it all are you sure oh no oh
[__] me man
and then it turned out to be cool I
think for the most part is you'll find
out that most people even even a lot of
the [__] haircuts that are on TV are
actually pretty funny when they're not
on there and they kind of get it it's
just they have to be more careful
how they word things and I don't have
anything to lose like I'm a poor man's
trophy wife I have my real estate
broker's license so I'm not working for
anybody other than like yeah I'm getting
clients out of this which has been great
another thing thanks to Jeremy because
he got me clients for to actually make
money and he got me votes in my own
account in my own District so thanks
Jeremy again
uh but poor would you say a poor man's
trophy Poor Man's trophy was a good life
one of our comic friends I started out
my life as strong independent woman now
I'm a strong dependent woman
Pace but also one of our we were doing
comedy Fight Club I'll never forget the
joke they were roasting each other she
goes you look like a participation
trophy wife a participation Trophy Wife
which is what a great [__] line man
but that's good man I mean I mean it is
it is it is funny to see these
politicians feel uncomfortable like I
think that to me is is politicians and
journalists feeling uncomfortable to me
it's like better than porn and something
I swear to God because they they get so
bitter because they they've literally
controlled literally controlled the
narrative like for so long and seen like
every time I man I don't care there's
nothing better than me than when
Community notes just destroy something
on Twitter it's just you because and I
know it's something simple that we
should have always had right which is
just people going like no here's
actually the truth if you want to see it
you know but but there's something about
you net them being accountable to them
is like it's like they're 911 like they
cannot handle being accountable you see
them falling apart because they got
everything wrong nobody trusts them they
literally are incapable of going hey my
bad him I'm sorry that's all Jeremy who
docks me I literally did an expose on
expose on him pretending to be a
journalist saying he doxed my friend
right and so what did he do to teach me
for exposing it he did it to me too like
these people are psychopaths they're
complete Psychopaths for him to do that
like he was teaching me a lesson for
exposing him for being a [__] person you
know but these people are these people
are all [__] [__] people but they do
it on here's the thing man it's like
money is basically worthless now let's
be realistic here so at this point it's
cloud cloud is the only thing that we
have close to being like any sort of any
any sort of any sort of recognition is
now Cloud so to them it's like man look
we watch news and basically local news
you know you know what it is local news
is is YouTube for the elderly because
they don't know how to use computers
because who the [__] gets home like
anybody gets home and goes man let me
turn on the local news and the weather's
on my [__] phone and I really don't
care if the story is big enough it'll
[__] pop up in Twitter you know what
I mean like I don't need I don't need it
anymore that's where all the news goes
first is Twitter anyways well that's
where all the journalists steal their
[__] stories from that's why they're
all [__] mad too
you know and and it's it it's just even
even in such a small space like think
about it like
they still control Google I mean they
still [__] control Facebook they
still control Microsoft they still
control everything but just a little
tiny little space on the internet
Twitter a little tiny spec in the grand
scheme of things them just losing that
is making them [__] Panic Keith
olberman screaming at the screen again
oh that was he's my favorite yeah I love
that man I I can't stop to this day now
it will always be synonymous with his
phone verified but he was just screaming
about the facts tell them next time
they're afraid and it's like he has his
laminated
the whole [__] video is bizarre I was
Triple boosted he had a laminated
[__] thing around his neck with all
of his [__] little cards like and he
was phone literal foam shooting out of
his mouth still not leaving his [__]
apartment in the Upper West Side
screaming about how everybody in Florida
that was just running around having pool
parties with our guns shooting him in
the air and getting drunk like like we
were afraid like we the ones that were
like yeah put my kid in a normal school
with other human children so they learn
how to not be a [__] school shooting
psychopath in a few years and he was our
operator yeah look at this guy we're the
ones who's afraid yeah look at
the shot
there it is
these people act like this don't try to
make us look like like we're the dummies
you had it laminated it's like you'd
look like a [__] [__] what a [__]
dork he's a [__] dork he's a [__]
dork in a [__] and a dork and that's
he's telling you they're afraid of the
guy who hasn't didn't leave his house
for two years no Keith I can assure you
I'm not afraid of you
and it is it is time to stop cobbling
them the ones who won't get the damn
shot already how many glasses do you
have you [__] [__] Mr Rogers of
glasses [__] serious every room he
walks into he's got to change his
glasses oh [__] so nobody wants to be
this [__] guy's neighbor because it's
just been screaming on the balcony every
night this guy [__] sucks
and our first power
and half losers
like elevated they're the worst people
in the world are like like the spelter
the [__] like how is he like how are
these terrible awful people they got a
big voice like they're the worst [__]
people ever they're not attractive no
one like they're awful they suck they
just [__] talk they're like the worst
12th grade girl or 12 year old girls but
it's to be fair to be fair oberman's
really not all that elevated anymore
he's been having a rough patch he's
starting to live off that ESPN he's kind
of a Locale now where people only cover
him because he's crazy like he's nuts
like he's just like let's laugh at this
old out of touch man like what Howard
Stern is now I believe he has made no
less than three drunken phone calls in
the last few years to Dan Patrick like
hey old buddy uh just you know if you
want to talk about you know the old
[__] round ball again give me a call
no nobody wants to work you're fine but
Dan Patrick's happy now and the people
that are elevated but it's it's it's by
Design right I mean it's it's just
getting enough people with enough Club
there people look well I'm let's be
realistic most people that are in the
[__] Media or Hollywood everything
most of them have sold their [__]
soul a long time ago now what's just
happening during coveted it was all it
was the people in power caching in their
[__] debts on them we're like oh hey
you were famous now here's what's here's
the script go [__] read it and guess
what you're gonna sing imagine I don't
care if you think it's cringe you're
gonna sing imagine because imagine I
tell everybody at the video about you on
Epstein Island you imagine that that's
really why they're they're pushed
because they're all they're all
compromised I mean they have to be
compromised this isn't rational thinking
Keith Urban got suspended on off of
Twitter for three days it was using his
dog shelter account to scream at Elon
Musk that's a [__] nut job
and they have to do like humiliation
rituals I saw that a lot during covert
were like random celebrities would do
this weird stuff and you're like the
[__] do they have on you what did you
just get threatened with to do that [__]
you know like I want I want that flight
log I want that flight log that flight
log I want it that was uh that was one
of the theories we came up remember when
I said I was like this is a humiliation
ritual I called it the day that Bill de
Blasio was out there with like a side
work like a sideways Brooklyn Nets hat
which is Shake Shack and he's like hey
what's up cool homies I want to rap to
you about the facts and it was so I'm
like bro that's humiliating he didn't
spend your whole life being a fake
politician to do this like but you know
your name and change your name oh they
had them on something and he's like I'll
go chill the burgers with the Nets
tickets I guess like I look like such a
[__] because any normal because any
normal person who did not plunge his
dick into a baby on that island would go
no I'm not gonna then don't re-elect me
I'm not going on TV looking like a
[__] straight up [__] I'm gonna
look like a [__] douchebag bro the
only thing that outpowers that feeling
in life of Shame is well you want to
look at some of these pictures we have
in this manila envelope and you're like
no I don't want to see the pictures
either I'll go [__] push the [__]
bird oh look let me eat some fries that
go normal
yummy these are such good fries now you
always take a tiny bite of a fry and put
the fry down
these people are all alien robots
they're all [__] robots if you're a
human and those were good fries you'd be
shoveling them into your mouth like it's
normal Americans do
I've never seen somebody go um what a
very good friends it's always oh my God
you're beautiful you want your friend
first
[__] [__]
then answer your question is because
most of them probably [__] kids man I
mean that's the reason that's what it is
again there's so many embarrassing
rituals I watch these people go through
and I'm like no I'll just rather you
fire me I already made a couple mil I
could go write a book I'll be all right
but it's like they have something on you
that makes you go get out there and push
the french fries [__] and you're like
okay all right just don't tell them I
[__] that baby like you know what I mean
just don't tell them I [__] drank
that baby's blood I'll go through the
thing again
so I guess what I guess my question is
how high how far how much how much how
many vaccines are you willing to push to
go high in government like what's what's
your top like two three vaxes four five
boosters how many we doing
me yeah you
ever
and I never took any of the cope with
one I will not play that game no no we
never took him either you're like one of
these [__] freaks is gonna like stalk
me and do some weird ass I'll be in a
lifetime [__] movie here coming up
soon as my guess but yeah it will be
who's gonna play you what are the
lifetime actresses you got to think of a
lifetime accessibility it's called call
it libertarian desire or something like
that because it's lifetime no it would
be something like that right
oh God no uh that would [__] that [__]
I'm just telling you we get like who's a
washed up actress I don't know Alicia
Silverstone Alicia Silverstone could
like play you right think about it first
I've heard Chloe's fagini or whatever
how the [__] you say her name inclusive
Annie yeah all right well I gotta be
honest with you I've seen the movies
that woman's in and she'll do anything
on screen there's gonna be a lot of
there's gonna be a lot of recreated
sections what was that brown bunny where
she actually blew somebody in there for
real yeah what's his name
she's the one that got AIDS and kids oh
yeah
yeah all right versus giving aids to
kids like I did an Epstein Island yes
which is a different thing back to that
circling back man they're really gonna
love this interview oh they're gonna rip
you apart for being on our show there's
a lot of like my big thing is I kind of
look like the white Suburban [__] and
like that's a big part of my
constituency and like these leftist
white Suburban [__] are ruining
everything so if I can kind of like turn
them around a little bit and like fit
them like stop stop [__] doing [__]
to your kids because your Facebook group
will make fun of you like what the [__]
is wrong with you stupid ass [__] so
just go out there in your Lululemon
holding an AR Lululemon yoga pants and
an AR be like listen I'm one of you
I guess they're all probably like coke
heads or people heads so you know you
come out there you get their attention
you bridge the gap you're like out there
look I am one of you I too watch 90 Day
Fiance I I speak your language they are
fooling you and trying to kill your kids
please in the long long ago we were just
extreme couponers please listen to me
and then like she making a lot of sense
I've seen her IG feed okay I believe her
gotta learn you have to learn this you
gotta do the Santa's hands never fully
Clap the Santa's hands when you die it
works so anyway like you're playing an
accordion look all these are free tips
look at you get all these free tips from
us I mean this is amazing
that's the best part about like the
extra attention I got is just there's so
many cool people I mean Twitter's been
amazing for connecting with cool people
anyways right during the last three
years and then this [__] just blew it
all off even more I've had so many more
great connections and helpful people and
I love it like that's what community is
about right let's read some of these
donations uh loose [__] 79 two dollars
that's his name breaking the FDA just
rescinded the covet vaccine
authorization seen James O'Keefe's
Twitter okay is that true
uh
uh let me see we got some more here we
have apathetic Crow you heard it here
first book first first folks
um monkeys are going bananas for
neurolink pick yours up today no no do
not use it as an ad read for neural link
uh Ministry of dude I heard it I heard
you earlier everything starts with
Ministry sucks huh could you be less on
the nose please I'm trying to run a
business here LOL and it does everything
with Ministry sucks uh and do a c oh we
already got that we were that we were
that we were that
okay anyway what are what are you what
are you gonna plug you got to plug your
[__] so people can find besides your
Twitter which is a [__] nut house I
mean it really is and I mean that like
in a it's like a
NC-17 Pee-wee's Playhouse of craziness
is the only way to just that's the
greatest favorite right I have yeah it's
crazy I have cleaned it up I'm not
posting any more loads or nudes for a
while
and in the first place really
but yeah it was because I put it like
the artistic photo of me sitting in the
woods naked right of course Mommy right
and then like they banned me for over a
year on that and I was like I'll change
the [__] thing oh wait a second
there's so much porn on Twitter there's
so much you're not allowed in your
profile picture or your header okay okay
nudity was allowed in profile pictures
it would be all dick pics we all know
how y'all are it would be objective
excuse me I said mine would be Dick
Clark no
mommy
Rumble of course Mommy
what things there first one I mean you
have been wonderful to interview thank
you for coming on we we do appreciate it
and now people see we do have we don't
hate women we Let The Crazy Ones on
see that's a compliment trust me if you
weren't crazy you wouldn't be here
um we're [__] not I mean you heard
the first hour we're [__] insane
um those are great you're you're
hilarious well thank you we appreciate
it you are welcome you are welcome on
the show of course and we will make sure
we get the vote I don't know how many
people in your town probably listen I
was praying out a lot but still I would
say vote for you and then bigger and
better things I'm telling you we
couldn't Harvest ballot if you're dead
or this if you're dead especially we can
count your vote okay if you have any
dead relatives in the Colorado area make
sure they vote for Forest Mommy I mean
that's what we're saying here we are
going to commit election fraud
now they can write that and take it
seriously it's going to be hilarious
baiting these people so easy ballot
harvesting it works both ways it works
both ways we're allowed to do up to like
10 at a time so just do it that's right
see there you go that's it the perfect
there you go guys I thank you so much
for being on really do appreciate it you
were wonderful thank you so much and
hopefully people people have learned
about the life of the forest Mommy thank
you so much
thank you all right take it easy bye-bye
she was fun she was great she was
[__] great I I love I love that whole
pissing off other women by going it's
because I'm hot because they peep bro it
annoys her timeline makes them they
makes them show away it's like the Paris
Hilton like stop being poor yeah it's a
great troll because they got so [__]
angry uh and you know and also because
they should stop it